hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the 2019 FIBA
World Cup it's Maxie Murphy Oleg
reverses Peter Svidler Maxime eliminated
in the previous round Demetria Kovalenko
a very strong Grandmaster they went into
tiebreaks and the Peters fiddler
eliminated
Olivia d'etre mississippiana who of
course eliminated Hikaru Nakamura from
the competition so you know as closer as
you get to the finals it's of course
more more intense so without further ado
let's check it out it's a very long
theoretical struggle so we're not gonna
dwell too long on the opening but Maxime
opens with efore yeah sorry about that
with E 5 by swindler Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and now Bishop to b5 so the rule
opus is on the board we have a 6 more
fees defense brush up to a 4 and 9 to f6
with castles and Bishop to e7 rook to e1
and now b5 pushing the bishop back
Bishop to b3 and here three little
castles and we have c3 Maxime is
inviting swiller to go for d5 the
Marshall attack but Svidler perhaps
didn't check it for for quite a while so
he decides not to go for it which is a
shame is it's such a well interesting
opening he goes d6 so we remain in the
coil opus h3 by white enter now Knight
to a5 pushing the bishop back making
room for c5 with Bishop to c2 in the now
c5 with b4 by white and the Queen to c7
I just to give you an example this
opening is played so much that there are
over almost 6000 games in the database
with this exact same position Knight B
to d2 with C capture Sundy for C
captures and now Knight back to c6
pressuring the d4 pawn so maxime defense
at wave Knights the b3 and now a5
preparing a fourth to dislodge a well
the knight and capture on e4 with
bushropp to e3
maxime introduces another defender to
the pawn here also nicely develops the
bishop who makes a room for the rook to
come into the game and a 4 by swindler
we've not beat the detail in the now
Bishop to d7 connecting rooks developing
the bishop we look to see
and then our rook a to c8 with Bishop
back to d3 now the rook is nicely on
this open C file and now there are some
14 games in the database where Queen to
b8 was played and it is considered the
strongest move recommended by the engine
but similar goes Queen to b7 which is a
new move and it is as of move 18 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
what happens we have Queen to e2
developing the Queen the rooks are now
nicely connected also there is pressure
on the b5 pawn although there is no
immediate danger of capturing it as a
settler just goes h6 takes away the g5
square from White's pieces and here you
would actually be worse if you capture
it on b5 because Bishop captures runs
into Knight captures on d4 because this
comes with an attack on the Queen and
also there is now a double attack on the
bishop here on b5 sorry about that
so here you would just have Knight
character son before
Knight captures on d4 you would play
rook captures on c1 rook captures on c1
and now e captures on d4 and now first
as you don't want to lose too much
material first Bishop d6 attack the
Queen and after the Queen moves and now
you move your Bishop and after black
captures this pawn our black is up upon
but also in a in a better position so
this is one pawn that is not free for
grabs with a three by mvl and now he
captures on d4 so we're gonna see a lot
of traits here which of course Spitler
doesn't mind he has the black pieces he
wants to trade down you know have a
solid position and if an opportunity
arises take it if not take his chance
with the white pieces with Knight
captures Knight captures Bishop captures
rook captures and C 1 we have captures
on c1 and now as your bb fat pony still
hanging you don't have time to get your
rook into the game first b4 by settler
and ok
Knight to c4 that the C the C 4 square
has been vacated for the night now and
then now a cap be captors an a3 will be
capped résumé 3 and Bishop to b5 now
here swindler allows the maxime a nice
tactic maxime plays a knight to capture
son d6 it's a sort of a temporary pawn
sacrifice but he will win his piece back
with special characters on d3 Queen
captures and virtual captures on d6 so
for the moment
a purpose but not for long you cannot
play e5 c5 just runs into Bishop
captures on a3 and you lose the rook and
c1 but what you can do is just Bishop
captures on f6 and now of course if
black captures you just recapture on d6
and there's your piece back so we have
Bishop the f4 sailor again goes for the
rook and c1 and now rook the b1 first
with an attack on the Queen Queen to c7
and now the bishop just retreats we've
pushed back to c3 and now Ziggler is
finally free to bring the rook into the
game we have looked the d8 with an
attack on the Queen Queen to f3 and now
rook the c8 putting pressure on the
bishop here and the Bishop to b4 the
bishop is nicely on a nice diagonal here
guarding the a3 pawn and at some point
if if black allows it maybe go Queen d1
grab that pawn and maybe start pushing
your past a pawn if possible and here
Bishop the c1 it's it's a very nice move
as it completely blocks the white rook
from entering the game also next you're
going to go Queen to c2 and the black is
going to have well a very nice position
but here as well or played Queen to c1
check and it's of course a very nice
idea if the queen is captured if the
queen is captured you get check you have
to give up some material and it's
checkmate as the h2 square is covered by
the bishop but maxime brought his queen
back we have Queen to d1 and now swivel
er not interested in trading Queens he
goes back Queen to c4 so what do you
play here well you could you could grab
the a for pawn but then you lose the e4
pawn so here maxime play the g3 first he
doesn't want this brush up constantly
covering the h2 square so he doesn't
have any more background issues he can
move the Queen and the rook from the
back rank you can always go King to h2
and here the problem is swiller probably
thought that after Bishop to e5
that well Queen captures on a4 is coming
but the problem is if you play Queen
captures on a for now it seems like
white is up DuPont's completely winning
but black has Bishop captures on g3 now
and there's a it's a pretty equal
position now because if you capture the
bishop then you get Queen d4 check King
has to move
now queen - f - check so now after the
King moves you're gonna bring the roux
back Rick rook here threatening
checkmate and here white has to give up
the Queen and black of course will be
winning here but sweedler most likely
eater thought that this doesn't work or
he found a different line but there is a
move very interesting that he might have
missed so Hitler here played the Queen
captures on e4 so he sacrificed his
bishop for this very nice attack
maxime play the G captures on f4 and now
sweedler played rook the c6 preparing
rook to g6 check and now to give you an
idea for example if white plays
something like rock the c1 then okay you
get rook to g6 checking moves you get
Queen g2 check King moves you can go
Queen - if or King to e1 now you can go
route back to e6 check or if you don't
go here if you go up the board for
example King to e2 you can even go
Queenie for check and now if you return
it's a well draw by perpetual or if you
go further down the board then Queen
captures on f4 and so on and the white
is still a piece but his king is a well
running loose on an open board it's hard
to say engine will defend it but it's
hard to say if a human will be
comfortable defending this but there is
a one much better move that most likely
came as a surprise to sailor but it's
hard to say so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea that was
missed by black while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent room maker for your
bishop and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
the move is f5 this is very strong the
problem is if you try Bishop to d6 here
yes it blocks a rook to g6 but then just
Queen g6 check and after King moves and
now you capture the bishop rook captures
and white is no longer up a piece the
problem is after this f5 move it no
longer works because now
well rook the g6 is prevented with the
f5 pawn so really very nice if you found
it and also what it does it removes the
pawn from f/4 so now you can actually
play Bishop to d6 and after
the rook to g6 check is made retreat
with Bishop to g3 this is a well the
only defensive resource that was good
for white here maxime of course founded
similar captured on f5 and the now
Bishop to d6 and now queen g6 check is
nothing because you simply retreat with
Bishop to g3 there is no pawn on f4 so
just a beautiful defensive idea also if
you're thinking about route captures
here with the idea that if Queen
captures you capture the rookin b1
doesn't work because of the simple check
rope checks and then you pick up the
rookie or simply up a whole rook so
after Bishop to d6 we have Queen
captures on h3 by Svidler
but now rook to be for grabbing the d4
square with the rook now the Queen can
move as black can deliver no more checks
we have looked not there sorry rook rook
the c3 vice viler and now comes Luke the
d4 just consolidating with King to h7
putting a king to it to a safer Square
and now Queen captures on a4 just
grabbing that pawn now maxine created a
past a pawn we have Queen to f3 hoping
to get rook to c1 check in but Maxime
just retreats Queen to d1 and now
Quintus c6 hoping to get rook the c1 in
to win the Queen but Queen to f1 making
room for the rook on d1 and here it was
in this position unmoved 42 that Peters
waiver resigned the game and a wonderful
wonderful victory for Maxime Barcia
holograph who tomorrow well today
basically as I'm making the video today
has the black pieces against wheeler and
if he can hold the draw it will be he
goes he advances in the World Cup and
Spiller is out so he resigned as there
is nothing more to do here
MVL is up up of a bishop and you'll just
well further consolidate maybe move the
bishop here put the room behind the past
pawn start pushing it and that's just it
you don't really even have to struggle
to win this as failure of course knows
this he could pose problems for Maxime
start pushing on the Kings side really
try to complicate the position as much
as possible but he knows that Maxine
would really have to play the worst game
ever to
him not to be able to win this but yeah
and a little spoiler alert for those of
you who are maybe interested I have I've
actually seen the results of Game two
before making this video so I will
mention them now if you don't want to
hear it adjust you know skip but fiddler
and Maxime drew Game two of their video
2019 World Cup and that means Maxime
advances further into round five and
Peter Stiller is out of the Phaedo World
Cup so that that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Peter canary Ravindra Yoga car combos of
course key matheus craft and sadly
unsuited for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Phaedo
World Cup checking up on your
suggestions and so on so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day